so we've identified the problem
there is a pandemic of female delusion
in 2021 it is not getting any better
gentlemen around the panel one after the
other
uh i'll start with john i'm just going
to kind of go clockwise on my screen
around but uh
like what is your solution for men
living in 2021
on the issue of female delusion the
thing that bugs me about a lot of
channels out there
is all they do is they bring red meat
but they don't bring solutions with rule
zero i want actionable
advice guys dispense now john fitch go
ahead
right so a frame above everything
because their delusions are only going
to affect you if you allow them to pull
you out of your frame and who you are
and what you're doing um
like i said also earlier with with you
know a lot of stuff with these
chicks hey you treat it like your kids
telling you about their superhero
collection or or whatever you know
you don't need to correct them you don't
need to tell them or explain them or
break out graphs and numbers and tell
them why they're wrong
just just make them laugh and uh have
fun
and and just know that like you're
probably better off not
not settling until you're much older 35
or so so
get the experience to to find someone
maybe who's uh
not as deluded when you're when you're
ready to settle down if you ever want to
do that
which i don't know if it's even worth
these days um
just get them pregnant if you want to
have kids
ryan what is the solution to female
delusion
as i could argue the self-proclaimed
optimist on this panel
i'm telling you there's two things that
can give you hope
that's lugs and lads if you guys don't
know the acronym
that's lesbians until graduation and
lesbians after divorce
what that means is that girls are pure
limbic brain
the problem with everything we've talked
about here before is guys are talking to
frontal lobe
chicks say this chicks want that that's
all their frontal lobe
guys think that's what girls mean
because our frontal lobe and our limbic
system are kind of connected our
instincts and our thinking
girls is completely separate lesbians
until graduation tells you that a girl
can believe she's a lesbian in her heart
of hearts
until she graduates and then all of a
sudden she likes dick again
if a girl can decide and as a guy
there is no way you're like i was gay
for like five years but then i gave it
up it just wasn't for me
it never happens so that lets you know
girls are moldable
you will have your own lacy green out
there if you don't know she was a
feminist she was like a sex positive
feminist you know men were bad this men
were bad that
got a good [ __ ] all of a sudden she
became red pilled
and it's talking about the glory of men
so yeah
girls will act as shitty as you let them
and all of these ones you see acting
like a piece of [ __ ] on myron's thing or
a piece of [ __ ] on
like rich's feed those are chicks that
just haven't
met the right dick to get them to stop
all this nonsense now
if it's not you it's not your [ __ ]
problem
that's the other part stop dwelling on
ain't [ __ ]
chicks let them be ain't [ __ ] and go be
[ __ ]
somewhere with a girl who's more
pleasant and better looking
there's always an attractive woman out
there as long as you just keep the
fatties and the psychos away from you
and i'll leave it on that remember
they're only a lesbian until they find a
good dick apparently
yep true story all right aaron let him
have it what is the solution to
delusional women
very simple stay above the free uh when
i flew out to miami i watched 1917
because i was on delta
and you could watch movies so it was
pretty cool and you're just looking at
the trench warfare and all this chaos
and everything going on but then there's
a couple scenes where there's some
biplanes flying over
and you guys can ask why and how and
where
da da da da or you could just be a top
value guy
and that's what i mean stay above the
freight you want to be that pilot flying
over
no man's land you don't want to be in no
man's land in the trenches
and for the amount it's a lot of hard
work you got to go to the gym you got to
work out you got to earn some money
whatever else uh that's a lot of work
and effort but that is less pain and
agony and i would say less overall
effort over the course of your life
than some guy wallowing as a seven he's
he's like
top 30 35 just isn't
get them become that guy and have the
girls do all the work
and you going to the gym two hours a day
is going to a hell of a lot more
uh and save you a hell of a lot more
time than going to a nightclub or going
on tinder or dating profiles and things
like that
and there's two books all right there's
this thing called the book of numbers
and some unknown rookie author who may
have had some marginal success with this
one
but surprise surprise and both of the
books even though rich and i did not
collaborate or correspond on this uh i
think
it's my final chapter i know rich i
think it may be your final chapter
wow we came up with the same conclusions
become a high value
guy and just avoid all this avoid the
headache avoid the hassle
just be that top guy uh where the girls
are throwing themselves at you and then
you have to worry about it
it's just it's just an easier so that's
that's my practical advice for all the
men out there
all right the english gentleman what is
the solution to delusional women in 2021
two solutions right so i agree with
everything that's been said so far be
high value 100 frame mega important
don't allow your frame to to slip
um self-improvement in order to become
high value but two additional solutions
the first one is volume
and the second one is arbitrage okay
volume
you've got to be going out there and
you've got to just be talking to a load
of different women
okay it's got to just be part of your
lifestyle you know whether you're doing
daytime approach whether you do it day
game whether you're doing
you know night game when the club's open
whether you're doing tinder or a
combination of all of them
you need to just be talking to a vol a
large volume
of different women so that you are
bringing different people into your life
and then you shouldn't have to be
worried about this nonsense you know you
don't have to be
dealing with the short-haired karen
who's giving he's breaking your balls
about the fact that you're not a ceo or
whatever it is you know
just don't just don't date them and the
second thing is arbitrage okay
if you're in a country where this is a
major problem
and i speak as someone who's sitting
here in the uk and many of
my brothers on this panel are in the
united states of america
get the hell out go somewhere else i
mean it's kind of difficult at the
moment with kovid but you know
i have friends in you know brazil i have
friends
in um former the former soviet union
i've got friends in russia itself
um you know and they are not dealing
with these issues
in the main because culturally it's not
a thing
so if you have volume and you you know
just just take the opportunity to step
on a plane and go
somewhere else you won't have to deal
with half of this nonsense just don't
entertain it is the bottom line
you know i don't the kinds of women that
myron was interviewing on that show that
you guys were chatting to
you know i i just if i was out in a bar
situation i just wouldn't even deal with
those women do you know what i mean i
mean
okay yeah it's kind of entertaining to
watch and it's instructive and stuff but
in my real life i just don't you know
just don't engage with it
at all um so that would be my tips
all right uh rolo the rational male how
do we deal with delusional women in 2021
delusional um well i think
i agree with what everybody has said up
to this point i probably will agree with
everybody who comes after me so i'm just
gonna
throw that out there right now i have
said this and i'll say this again as i
think men and women are better together
than we are apart
and up until now um
because of what gynocentrism or whatever
you know
the sexual revolution whatever um we
have
sort of created a western society that
we are globally exporting right now
that is um that is creating
this that is it's funding this it's
creating this
it's a it's a gynus a gynocracy right
it's it's a
social order by women for women but i
think if
if uh if last week didn't teach you
anything it should teach you this
is that um women are necess and when
they get to be 29 or 31 they don't
realize
how necessary they are until they get to
that point where they're like oh my god
now i know that i cannot compete in the
sexual marketplace anymore
i still feel entitled to having the best
of the best
but when they are faced with the idea of
seeing the next crop of 22 year olds
come into the sexual marketplace
that's when they sort of have to have
their epiphany right
and i think it behooves men right now if
you want to deal with delusional women
i say don't deal with them at all i
would definitely uh agree with aaron's
try to stay above all of this but in
staying above it
you have to understand that the the more
valuable you make yourself as a man
the more you're going to have to protect
yourself i told fresh this as well i
said when you guys like myron when you
and you guys are doing your show and
everything
you have to be very careful because what
will happen is you'll get
you'll get some random girl on there who
says that you sexually harassed her on
that show
or she will and she'll try to lock you
down with a with a
unplanned pregnancy there's lots of ways
that women try to
hedge their bets let's just say um in
the sexual marketplace
by using by using the gynocentric social
order against you
whether you're going to marry them or
not so you have to be very careful
of you know how far you go with these
chicks when you're when you have them on
because again you're going to at some
point along the way you're going to get
to the girl who's going to go
who's going to file some sort of report
or some something against you for that
so you've got to protect yourself and
that i think that really kind of goes
for most guys as it is right now
so um and remember like harassment rape
all that other stuff
does not have a statute of limitations
so you've got to be
very careful in your in your dealings
with this assuming you want to deal with
them at all
but when you get to a point where you
are
like the maid guy right when when rich
says you know the the finish line where
women are waiting to bang the winners
when you get to that point you have to
realize that you are in a position of
sexual selection and you are in a
position of power that most women will
never attain in their lifetime
because they're already past it so when
you go and you're 36 years old and you
want to get with a girl that like the
guy was saying 39 and he was banging
some
23 year old girl that's the level of
sexual selectivity you will have when
you get to that point
most guys when they get there they they
blow their load or they shoot their load
before they even get to that point and
that's when they have like the epiphany
phase of them
of their own which is really sort of
their midlife crisis
you have to see the the force for the
trees
so when you're down in the trenches like
like aaron was saying if you're up above
that and you see things sort of in the
long term when i get to this point i
will have more
sexual selectivity then i'll decide
whether i want to have kids who i want
to get with who who's worth getting with
um thinking of yourself in you know
mental point of origin
right thinking of yourself as i all
these are the decisions that i'm going
to make
that are going to benefit whoever else
that i happen to get with later on
doesn't mean you have to be like you
know dr evil or anything it's just like
that's
you're in a position where you can make
those good choices and when you get to
that point
that's i think the point at which we can
start changing society a little bit more
when enough guys
are are unplugged from the matrix and
they understand this stuff and they
understand what their value
is that's when women get threatened
that's when women get like nervous when
a guy
understands his own sexual market or his
own real value to women
that's when women get get really
threatened that's why the girls who are
on all of these shows
that they'll default to that emotional
response
because they realize that ultimately the
guy that they want to get with the
highest value guy that they want to get
with he's in a position of selectivity
that they will never enjoy
and if they do it's only for a very
brief time in their lives
so they're looking at you that's why
women see men as i go the patriarchy and
they're oh so powerful
they have a potential for power that far
exceeds
a woman's over the course of a lifetime
but most guys never realize that
because they sell out before they get to
that point so it's
those realizations unlearning that that
blue pill conditioning i think that's a
number one and we're
starting to see guys right now suddenly
wake up
to the value that the red pill has had
for 20 freaking years right now
and now everybody wants a piece of that
so here here we are
right now and guys are starting to pick
up on this and you know what women are
getting nervous
all the chicks that were on myra show
last week they're all getting nervous
and so they would default to that that
emotional response
then lastly i think that we need to be
careful that we don't get wrapped up in
the emotional high
and the uh the outrage brokership or the
the youtube bloodsport
uh rush that comes from holding a woman
accountable
finally finally after 65 years of women
you know yay women you know
team woman gynocentrism whatever finally
after 65 some odd years of that
guys are saying you know what here's the
facts here's what's going on we have the
internet we have the data
you know we've been we've been
aggregating this over in the red pill
for over 20 years and now we're
presenting presenting
our case and women are getting nervous
and
i think we get wrapped up too much in
the the mgtow kind of thing where it's
like yeah women are going to get theirs
they're going to get their comeuppance
and i think we need to make sure that if
we're going to do that as sort of an
attraction like the sizzle is the
attraction to bring guys in
to understand this or even women to
understand this that there also has to
be substance that goes along with that
um myron you're up next before i put you
on the screen we have almost 3 500
people watching hey and just over a
thousand thumbs up take your take your
mouse your thumb on your tablet whatever
you're on just slide it over hit the
thumbs up button
there's 29 delusional women that hit the
thumbs down do me a favor hit the thumbs
up
byron you're up buddy full screen uh
what is the solution to the delusion of
women
in uh 2021 uh there's no solution for
them the only solution for men is is
this
because women aren't going to concede
any of the leverage they have in the
marketplace so the only thing you could
do as a guy
is as i was saying earlier has become
high value because what women what
feminism has done really is
it's it's allowed it's really put the
top five percent
ten or five to ten percent of men in the
driver's seat because all the women are
chasing them now since they don't need
the provisioning anymore
so i say this keep it short and short
and sweet
get get your value up high and then work
more volume a lot of guys problems that
come with women stem 90
of the time from now working enough
volume i agree 100 with troy you got to
get out there use online dating
you gotta talk cold approach girls at
the club bar grocery store whatever it
is
you got to use social circle game
instagram everything leverage all your
assets
to get after uh if you want to meet
women to get
get out there and meet women because
because the thing is that since women
are so
delusional the flake rate is high what's
happened is since women are delusional
have a high perceived sense of worth
they flake on more guys than ever before
even top shelf guys get flaked on so the
only way you're going to combat that is
you got to work a lot of volume so get
your value high
work a lot of volume and you're going to
have a lot better success
all right uh modern life dating johnny
boy what's up brother what is the
solution
oh man you know you just gotta you just
gotta forget about him like
um just chat the [ __ ] out go to the gym
a lot
get in shape and right now you know when
in doubt
you know we're kind of in this limbo
position in human history with this
whole
uh beer bug situation so just figure out
how to make more money
that's what we're talking about right
now um on
you know with what's uh going on with
charlie's course and
you know i've been doing the tokyo
crypto show forever um
but you know these girls they're just
like they're totally not worth
anything other than like straight up
ejaculate and evacuate
this is what they have reduced
themselves to
no i don't want to cook for no man no i
don't need your money
no i'm not gonna clean up after you what
am i your mother okay so what does that
reduce you to you that has reduced you
to a sexual object
i'd rather die alone yeah i'd rather die
alone or
here's my dog blah blah right you know
um so
guys and honestly look i'm one of the
few that
that put my money where my mouth is i
saw where america was going i said [ __ ]
this
i am not spending my sexual prime
in this [ __ ] and i booked it out to
a first world nation in asia
and i'm living the dream i am living the
dream my sex life is
fantastic i am satiated
i am a little sick right now i have
women in nursing me back to health i am
living the dream if you have the balls
and the resources
you know whether you do online work
remote work
or you know property management you own
a couple properties
and you can get out you don't have kids
child support none of that
get the [ __ ] out of america go live
somewhere else
it is totally like the rest of the world
is a pretty nice place you know
um that's what i say but at the end of
the day like look and these girls you
know that
that [ __ ] uh that dumbo armed karen
check on on myron's channel dude that
chick
is she's just a testimony these girls
are they're like you know like when you
watch
a zombie movie and like the zombies just
like this incorrigible sick like thing
like
ah there's no reasoning with it like
that's what the when this is
this is what happens when these girls
take the feminism pill
they just become like these feminism
zombies and you can't
you can either [ __ ] kill them or just
let them kill themselves
that's the only way to solve it so we're
not gonna kill these [ __ ]
but like you know that's just that's
like an easy way to put it they
are mentally like brainwashed and
a lot of them don't figure it out so buy
cat food stock you know like [ __ ] bet
on
whatever it takes to to monetize their
fall
because i do not give a good god damn
um paul you you kind of hit on yours
in your rant earlier can you sum it up
in a couple of minutes
again just what the solution is to the
delusion
yeah i co-sign what everybody's saying
of course and we're all saying similar
things just in different ways
um but the the level of
uh we'll say your quality of life
all right with women and the women in
your life is a function of your sexual
market value
your skill with women and opportunity
okay those three things so if you don't
have good experiences with women in your
life your lab
and one of those three things all right
you got to work on your smv
work on your skill which oftentimes
means doing less
or all right so alpha guys actually do
less
and they get bigger results with women
all right so just kind of think about
that so a lot of you guys are trying way
too hard
you know what i mean any guys will go
guys will get discouraged god so much
work
you know juice isn't worth the squeeze
no it's very little effort actually
once you have the skill set it's it's
pretty effortless
use a little like a quick jiu jitsu
example right
if a black belt's rolling with a bunch
of white belts it's pretty effortless
for him
you know what i mean to make these guys
tap out because he has a high
level of skill whenever you have a high
level of skill with something
that means you get you put as much
effort or time or energy in order to get
the results that you want
so boost your skill up too you know
boost your skill up with women learn
game
learn how to maintain your frame right
be that alpha guy which cuts right
through the [ __ ]
all the delusion and stuff that's out
there it you cut
right through it when you know how to as
i say speak to her vagina
right and uh last thing i just want to
expand on okay
vagina whisper last thing i want to
expand on is opportunity
all right there's also the issue of
opportunity cost
so you know myron and is dead on
troy's dead on with you know getting out
there and getting your numbers up
but it's not just getting your numbers
up there's the other part which is
opportunity cost which means nexting
women very quickly
all right a lot of you guys let women
into your lives that are fives
you know that are not good partners
even as casual partners assisting into
your life they bring you problems
i estimate about seven out of ten women
are not going to be good women at all
for you to bring into your life and out
of the three out of the ten that might
be
a good that could be a good compliment
two of them either aren't gonna like you
or you're not gonna like them
you got about a a ten percent chance out
there
and so if you're not nexting women which
is what spinning plates is not
just about having a harem of women it's
about getting rid of women that don't
compliment you you're missing
opportunities then you're focusing
because you only have a finite amount of
energy and time you can put into
something in a 24 hour
a week basis do you put your energy and
time into women
that are just not worth it you know
they're not a good time they're not
compliments um and fi and so stop doing
that right next these women
and my final thought is just be the
example
like guys are you got these trad cons
like going to save the world through
institutions
how about just save your household you
know what i mean
save yourself because here's what
happens when you save yourself
you you have a great i'm having a great
time with women in my life
a great time you know in the united
states in the detroit area
which is arguably like the worst area to
have a time with women
all right like there's a lot of crap
there's a lot of
not so good women are me you know
in in but it doesn't matter i have a
great time
what happens is the women that you have
in your life
become an advocate for you and your
behavior because they're
they have emotional buy-in i mean you
guys are busy
on a date trying to argue with a girl
over a 50-50 partnership
and trying to out-reason and logic her
into you know gonna try to reason your
way into her vagina
and into her or not being a feminist
it's not gonna work
what you need is emotional buy-in women
do things and make changes due to their
emotions
and how they feel about it so you have
to have what i call
buy-in right so when you're creating
great experiences for yourself and de
facto
they're having great experiences you
become an example
more people want to be like you more
girls want what you have
you know want what her girlfriend has
you know what my ltr has
that sort of thing and that's how you
make some changes you just focus on you
and there's a ripple effect if all you
guys in the chat right now
or all you guys watching right now three
thousand
would just work on you right now and
that would have that ripple effect
within your circles
make a much bigger difference than
trying to attack an institution
so all right the final word
uh from yours truly i i saved the super
chat to kind of put it up to sum up what
i wanted to talk about i think
everybody's got
very good points uh the goddamn bacon
says uh solution become the five percent
let them chase you you always lose
progress chasing women you never lose
women chasing progress you're the catch
here there's a reason why these are on
my mugs right
shout out to the uh teespring store in
the merch store
but um i don't think that you can put
enough emphasis
on yourself setting boundaries and
not giving a [ __ ] basically i mean
everybody made some excellent points and
it really boils down to
be a top shelf man set boundaries and
enforce them
and have options and that's really what
it boils down to and yes
there'll be a lot of delusion out there
and yes you're going to have to point to
the front door and tell a lot of them to
pound sand and
you'll ghost them and you're going to
have a little bit of drama from time to
time but
um there still are some very
you know decent i'm not going to say you
know there's a one out there for you but
there's some decent women out there that
want to enter your frame that want to
complement your life that
that want to go along for the ride and
aren't gonna you know routinely
continuously
uh ongoingly [ __ ] test you over dumb
[ __ ] that is that is based on female
delusion um you're constantly gonna have
to enforce the boundaries though it's
it's
it's it's just it's just the reality of
it all
you